the issue of trade has been a big part
of our discussion so far when we think
of trade we typically think of physical
or material goods such as clothing or
cars but property can also be immaterial
that is we have a property in our ideas
or intellectual property so if we design
a new piece of clothing or we design in
a new car we own those ideas that gave
rise to the goods
James Madison had these two kinds of
property in mind the material and the
immaterial when he wrote is 1792 essay
on property
Madison there was discussing the
individual's inalienable ownership of
his own natural rights with which we are
of course all endowed by our Creator
including the right to use our minds and
have opinions and direct our own free
will we might call it our first or
foundational intellectual property well
the theme for our lunch talk today is
the theft of US intellectual property
the issue remains one of abiding
political importance in August of this
year President Trump issued an executive
memorandum related to China and the
theft of intellectual property well to
help us think through this vital topic
we are fortunate to have with us the
acting chairman of the Federal Trade
Commission she has many years of
experience working at the FTC and has
served as a commissioner since 2012 a
lawyer by training she has previously
been a partner at Wilkinson Barker and
Knauer where she focused on trade issues
and she has clerked for Judge David B
santel at the US Court of Appeals for
the DC Circuit she's the author of a row
of a variety of articles on competition
law privacy and technology matters and
she graduated with distinction from the
Antonin Scalia Law School at George
Mason University where she was also a
professor and also graduated with honors
from the University of Virginia so if
you would join me in welcoming to the
podium
Maureen Olhausen
[Music]
[Applause]
get my paper is arranged here well good
afternoon everyone
and many thanks to Hill Hillsdale
College and the free market forum for
hosting this important conference I very
much enjoyed the discussions last night
in this morning and I'm pleased to join
you today to talk about the importance
of intellectual property rights in the
US so as Tim mentioned I'm going to talk
about the theft of US intellectual
property but but but I'll put a little
spin on it which is why should we care
why should we care about the theft of US
intellectual property and at the risk of
giving away the punchline to my speech
I've entitled it strong patent rights
strong economy and so I'll talk to you
today about the importance of strong
patent rights to the US economy and what
I can do as the chairman of the Federal
Trade Commission to encourage respect
for these important rights around the
world but first a few foundational
points now America's founders understood
the importance of protecting property
including intellectual property the
Constitution wisely provides that
Congress shall have power to promote the
progress of science and useful arts by
securing for limited times to authors
and inventors the exclusive right to
their respective writings and
discoveries the US Court of Appeals
through the federal circuit which
handles patent matters in the u.s.
observed that if one were to eliminate
the right to exclude from the basket of
Rights attached to patents the express
purpose of the Constitution and Congress
to promote the progress of useful arts
would be seriously undermined now note
the inclusion of useful arts among the
drafters goals their intent was clearly
to entice inventors with the lure of
exclusive rights the Supreme Court
recognized the important role of this
system to provide an incentive to
innovators assuming to inventors to risk
the often nor
miss costs in in terms of time research
and development the productive effort
thereby fostered will have a positive
effect on society through the
introduction of new products and
processes of manufacture into the
economy in exchange for this reward for
inventions the patent laws require the
inventor to disclose his or her idea so
that after the period of exclusivity
expires the public benefits from knowing
about the public can benefit from
knowing about and using that invention
freely the founders knew then what some
seemed to be overlooking today strong
intellectual property rights promote a
vibrant economy by encouraging
innovation
despite the founders wisdom and
foresight and in over 200 year history
during which the United States driven by
technological innovation emerged as the
world's leading economy a movement is
underway to undermine US patent rights
op-eds call for limiting patent rights
reputable sources like The Economist
magazine voiced a skeptical tone some
technology firms claim that patent
lawsuits are owed their R&D budgets and
bottom line and there have even been
calls to abolish the patent system now
emerging economies around the world view
these statements through their own
prisms of history and economic pressure
often citing them as justifications to
disregard or diminish protect legal
protections for us propriety proprietary
technologies in their own countries few
developing countries combat piracy for
example now some scholars assert that
influential jurisdictions appear to use
their any trust powers not to protect
competition but instead to regulate the
price of patent rights in particularly
US patent rights but supporters of
inventors rights shouldn't despair the
United States
can continue to lead the way in
protecting the rights of deserving
inventors and encouraging other
countries to do the same as the acting
chairman of the Federal Trade Commission
I have consistently advocated for struck
for protecting to intellectual property
rights both domestically and abroad now
two fundamental principles guide my
approach first strong patent rights are
crucial to economic success and secondly
for all your Kannamma sin the audience
economically grounded analysis will
reveal the right path through the
thicket of IP skepticism and I look
forward to discussing these two
principles with you today so first the
importance of IP rights innovation
drives the development of new and
improved products and services
it meets society's greatest challenges
in areas as diverse as energy production
telecommunications and medical research
but innovation is not easy it involves a
winding road from idea to invention
through development to commercialization
each of these steps can be risky
expensive and unpredictable the goal of
the patent system is to promote
innovation in light of this risk and
uncertainty it does so by granting
patent owners the right to exclude
others from making using or selling a
patented invention for 20 years
patents create a property right for
intangible ideas which makes licensing
them easier and facilitates the sharing
of these technological ideas this
property right also protects innovators
from copying that could drive down
prices and deter future investment these
patent rights have real-world effects
the United States government recently
reported that IP intensive industries
support at least 45 million US jobs and
contribute more than six trillion
dollars or about slightly over 38% of US
gross domestic
empirical research supports the
fundamental role that patent rights play
in promoting innovation and I've written
at length most recently in the Harvard
Journal of law and technology about the
positive correlation between IP rights
and R&D investment in developed
countries so let me give you an idea of
some of the research the evidence that I
found so for example scholars who
examine data from 60 countries between
1960 and 1990 to explore the
relationship between IP rights and
economic growth found that intellectual
property rights affect economic growth
by stimulating the accumulation of
factor inputs like research and
development capital and physical capital
other researchers scrutinized data and
R&D investment and patent protection
from 32 countries between 1981 and 1995
and this evidence unambiguously
indicated the significance of
intellectual property rights as
incentives for spurring innovation in
countries which provided stronger
protection tended to have larger
proportions of their GDP devoted to R&D
activities a host of other empirical
work finds a statistically significant
relationship between patent strength and
R&D investment a 2013 Brookings report
observed research has established that
patents are correlated with economic
growth across and within the same
country over time an R&D spending since
1953 is highly correlated with patenting
and the patent rate in studying US data
between 1980 and 2010 the report
concluded that patenting is associated
with higher metropolitan area
productivity and that the most likely
explanation is that patents cause growth
now we also know that firms respond to
changes in the strength of patent
protection a well known study for
example examine the u.s. semiconductor
industry between 1979 and 1995
it found that large-scale manufacturers
have invested far more aggressive
patents during the periods associated
with strong US patent rights even
controlling for other known determinants
of patenting so the solid theoretical
and evidentiary justifications for
intellectual property rights don't mean
that granting ever stronger patent
protection will inevitably lead to even
greater innovation and there is a need
to scrutinize the quality of patent
applications and to calibrate
appropriate compensation that should
take into account the incentives that
drive R&D in various settings and some
limited patent reform may also be
appropriate to identify to address
identified problems such as insufficient
quality control the broad scope of
certain patent rights an inadequate
disclosure nevertheless strong patent
rights should remain at the heart of
u.s. industrial policy so now I'll turn
to all this IP skepticism that we're
experiencing today recent criticism of
the patent system requires some
explanation what drives cause to
diminish or even eliminate the US patent
system I think several factors are
responsible for example patenting
technologies and commercializing them
are increasingly separate acts
undertaken by different entities and
connected by patent licenses if at all
after the fact so someone manufactures a
product and then tries to get the
license for it for the for the patent
now one effect of this evolution has
been the rise of patent assertion
entities known as PA es now PA es are
businesses that acquire patents for
third parties and then try to make money
by negotiating with her suing accused
infringers and patent litigation has
become more frequent and complex making
enforcing and defending against patent
claims expensive and finally there's
been a trend towards granting broad
patents which the Supreme Court has
started to reverse now the implications
of all those factors are complicated but
even if today's
system and associated litigation costs
sometimes produce imperfect outcomes
they don't undermine the patent systems
core function
today's patent regime drives a varied
complex and evolving array of
technologies the markets in which novel
products and methods arise are
themselves changing now of course there
are imperfections in how patents execute
their mission but some such
complications are no reason to abandon
the patent system wholesale instead
policy makers should take an
economically and empirically grounded
approach to IP issues and this view
recognizes the many benefits of patent
protection while accepting that some
revisions may be necessary to promote
innovation so I'll describe two recent
FTC initiatives that exemplify my
position in the first the FTC gathered
extensive empirical evidence to support
carefully tailored recommendations and
in the second no evidence support is a
substantial change and I advocated for
the retention of traditional
intellectual property principles now the
first initiative involved patent
assertion entities as I already
mentioned PA ES and they do not create
IP themselves but but rather by and
license patents to manufacturers and
others and their activities create
strong views some commentators decry PA
EES this hi-tech extortionists that tax
innovators but others respond that PA es
that and licensing markets in which
individual inventors can monetize their
technologies and manufacturers can
secure the permissions they need to sell
their products lawfully but claims on
both sides however have been light on
facts and rather heavy on aspersions and
that is why I supported the use of the
FTC's research authority to study PA e
markets and produce a report which
discloses previously unknown facts about
how PA e
right now the report on advances our
understanding of PA es and their role
within the patent and innovation system
it was a case study and it covered PA
EES that may account for over 75 percent
of all US patents held by PA es at the
end of 2013
now it's full of relevant findings of
unavailable in other studies and while I
can't discuss all of them here after all
this is just a lunch a few conclusions
are worth noting for their contribution
to larger policy discussions for me the
standout conclusion was that there was
no single PAE business model rather our
research suggested that there were two
main types one of which we call
portfolio PA EES and the other recalled
litigation PIL opae s apparent that
aggregate hundreds of or thousands of
patents licensed their portfolios for
millions of dollars apiece and
capitalized themselves through
institutional and other investors and
despite making up only 9% of the
licenses in the study they generated
four-fifths of the revenue they hire
specialized IP licensing professionals
and typically negotiate licenses without
first suing their prospective licensees
the manufacturers so all told portfolio
PA EES engage in conduct that's
potentially consistent with an efficient
aggregation service putting together
complementary patents and offering an
easier licensing regime to people who
want to use those those patents and
given the sums that change hands and
arms links transactions between
portfolios pas and their licensees
amounts that seem to exceed any
litigation cost
it appears that technology users paid
sums that reflect or may refer reflect
the quality of the license patents so by
contrast litigation PA EES generally
sued technology users without first
negotiating and then they would settle
shortly thereafter after they filed a
lawsuit and the portfolio's that they
license often comprise no more than a
few
and they generated royalties that were
typically less than $300,000 and this is
an amount that accused infringers could
expect to spend through initial
discovery in litigation so it was a kind
of their initial litigation costs so
given the relatively low dollar amount
of licenses the behavior of litigation
paes164 the lawsuits in the study and
representing about 91% of licenses they
accounted for only 20% of revenue now to
be clear infringement litigation plays a
very important role in protecting patent
rights the ability to sue others for
copying your invention is crucial to
establishing the property boundaries
necessary to promote innovation but at
the same time nuisance litigation which
relies an estimated costs and not the
strengths of the patents claimed can tax
judicial resources and divert attention
away from productive business behavior
so accordingly the FTC's report
presented tailored recommendations to
alleviate potential litigation abuses
for example it proposes case management
practices that could mitigate the
litigation cost asymmetries between
payee plaintiffs and defendants and we
also recommended the Congress passed
rules increasing transparency and
encouraging courts to stay litigation by
PA es against end-user so you've all
heard about the you know the coffee shop
being sued but when parallel proceedings
are already underway against the
manufacturer and the manufacturer the
product that may be the small business
is using and I've supported these
proposals because they're narrowly
tailored to address observed behavior
without leading to unintended
consequences well beyond PAE activity so
the second FTC initiative where I didn't
see evidence to support substantial
change involved the recent revision of
our IP licensing guidelines so in
January of this year the Federal Trade
Commission and the US Department of
Justice Antitrust Division issued
jointly issued updated antitrust
guidelines for the
licensing of intellectual property which
states the agency's enforcement policy
with respect to the licensing of IP
protected by patent copyright and trade
secret law and this is the first update
of our guidelines since 1995 and it's
occurred you know after the time where
there's been all this criticism and
ferment involving for the protection of
intellectual property
so although IP licensing is generally
pro-competitive antitrust enforcers do
have a role to play in protecting
against competitive abuses now in the
past I've expressed concern when less
like-minded overseas enforcers often in
in Asia apply there any trust laws to
dilute US IP rights and doing so
inappropriately morphs antitrust law
into a tool for price regulation and
creates harmful disincentives for
innovation I'm pleased to say that the
2017 guidelines exemplify my approach to
any trust IP issues and offer reasonable
guideposts more importantly the new
guidelines continue of to affirm that IP
law grants enforceable rights which have
social value and they also state that
antitrust laws generally do not impose
liability on a firm for unilateral
refusal to assist its competitors so
read together with the FTC and do J's 20
2007 IP report which stated that
liability formule mere unconditional
unilateral refusals to license will not
play a meaningful part in the interface
between patent rights in antitrust
protections it's clear that the
guidelines will continue to protect
strong IP rights in the United States
now some commentators called upon the US
agencies to create new specialized
guidelines to address particular types
of IP disputes and I didn't support this
because the available evidence did not
require major changes to the
Commission's approach and as I've said
before IP issues are not a special case
that requires a different competition
jurisprudence for more than 20 years the
guy
lines have offered general guidance that
has adapted to new and complicated
issues in the IP space and under this
precedent we should be careful not to
establish new standards without
compelling evidence to do so so just to
conclude patents have been at the heart
of US innovation since the founding of
our country and respect for patent
rights is fundamental to advance
innovation the United States is more
technologically innovative than any
other country in the world this reality
reflects in part the property rights
that the US government grants to
inventors still some foreign
counterparts take or aloud the taking of
American proprietary technologies
without due payment for example emerging
antitrust regimes view unfairly high
royalties as illegal under their any
trust laws and the FTC's recent policy
work that I've just mentioned offers an
important counterweight to this approach
illustrating the important role that
patents play in promoting innovation and
benefiting consumers in closing while we
may live in an age of patent scepticism
there is hope criticism of IP rights
frequently does not hold up upon closer
examination rather empirical research
favors the close tie between strong IP
rights and R&D but this isn't to say
that changes to the patent system are
always unwarranted rather the key to
addressing the US patent system lies in
incremental adjustments where necessary
based on a firm empirical foundation so
the US economy stands as a shining
reminder of everything that American
innovation policy has achieved and
intellectual property rights and patents
are the important cornerstones of those
achievements so thank you for your
attention and I look forward to
addressing your questions
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah Vince please raise your hand at the
microphone will be brought to you
yes a couple of questions one to what
extent is China the lead country in
terms of violating some patent rights
and two has there been any special look
at drug companies who and this has been
in the news lately who have taken
patents and and just used them to
increase their prices to the point where
it's almost unaffordable for people who
need the particular drug so taking your
first question there has been good
research other parts of the government
have looked at IP law violations in
China and it has been a problem but we
see it in other emerging countries as
well we see it in India and you know
other other parts of Asia and one of the
challenges that I've had to address is
there's outright piracy right where
someone says I'm just gonna copy this
movie or I'm gonna copy those shoes or
something like that but the problem that
I've really had to address is an
antitrust enforcer is we're there any
trust laws are being interpreted to say
well we want more competition you talk
about competition competition is a good
thing and the way we get more
competition is we get more competitors
and the way we get more competitors is
that competitor has invented something
really valuable so that competitor must
share it with everyone else in the
market and then there's you know so that
and then they say and we also have an
unfair pricing part of our law so it has
to be at a price that we you make
perhaps a state-owned enterprise think
is the fair price so that's how many
trust law is being distorted to in
effect allow the misappropriation of
u.s. intellectual property at an unfair
rate now your question about patents and
informa suitable so that's an issue the
FTC has paid a lot of attention to
because I talked a lot about the
importance of innovation and strong
patent rights and that has been shown to
be very strong a very strong correlation
in the pharmaceutical industry
in particular so a lot of the research
has shown that in particular strong IP
rights has led to a lot of innovation in
pharmaceuticals but one of the
challenges that we've seen and tried to
address is that a company you know you
get your patent for about 20 years but
you don't get to extend it beyond that
through basically misusing the
regulatory process or entering an
agreement with your competitor not to
enter the market so that's where the FTC
has tried to focus that so next month on
November 8th I have announced them
during a workshop at the Federal Trade
Commission and the Food and Drug
Administration is going to be part of it
that's looking at this issue we've got a
lot of drugs that are no longer
protected by patents but we haven't seen
generic drugs enter the market yet and
to say well what is the problem there is
that a regulatory hurdle is it in any
competitive problem how can we in the
government use our tools not to devalue
IP rights but to say well you know you
already got the full measure of your IP
how come someone else isn't coming in
and using it freely in the IP right free
market determines the price with the IP
rights the price is very difficult to
determine especially at the initial
stages and also there are some
discoveries innovation in
pharmaceuticals where let's say
discovery for cancer and the country or
the nations that require this particular
remedy from let's say a visor is very
very expensive how is the price of the
drug is determine given the dilemma of
the cancer patients so the question
about the inventor right of a very
valuable technology whether it's in
pharmaceuticals or it's in some you know
other technology
the idea that they are able to get a
high price for that because it's a
product a lot of people want is a
fundamental part of our IP right system
so the Supreme Court has talked about
this that you need to allow monopoly
profits to occur to address to attract
investment and innovation in an area I
think some of the the problems occur
though when you have either an
anti-competitive situation going on or
as I said where someone has entered into
some sort of in a competitive agreement
to preserve their monopoly beyond the
time period that it was granted under
you know under our patent laws that
that's one of the challenges and also
regulatory problems one of the issues
I've tried to focus on in my tenure is
the abuse of government process so as we
have more rules and as we have more
government we have more opportunities
for competitors to use the process
itself to keep out new forms of
competition so one of the first things
that I did as the acting chair was I
founded an economic Liberty task force
to focus on the abuse of government
process to stifle competition and we're
competitors we talked about some of
those speaker topic regulatory capture
this morning it's it's a it's something
we do see occur so the question I think
that that your that your concern
addresses is what do we do you know
you're you're you're good you should get
to reward for your invention but you
shouldn't get more than that award or
you shouldn't do it through being able
to divide up the market with your
competitor this is this is my economics
professor Ken L Zenith on better I
better be able to answer this question
no first of all thank you for your
remarks it's refreshing to see a
government official defend private
property rights
[Applause]
[Music]
so my question marine is this as you
know American antitrust law has wisely
and historically tried to stay away from
direct price regulation and part of what
you're saying is that when it comes to
antitrust authorities overseas that they
are using forms of price regulation to
try and capture private property rights
from American innovative firms what I
didn't understand is what the Federal
Trade Commission or the DOJ if you're
working with the Antitrust Division can
do to try and thwart antitrust
authorities who are trying to use that
strategy against American firms as what
is it a negotiating matter is it a
litigation matter what tools do you have
in your arsenal to try and stop that so
that's an excellent an excellent
question what can what can we do about
rape identified this problem what can we
at the FTC and the department justice do
about it so there are several ways we
try to address this one is by putting
forth what the right goal should be
right so to say here are international
best practices we engage with the
Organisation for Economic Cooperation
Development OECD we engage with other
world any trust bodies to say here
here's the right goal here's what we
should be going towards and then being
willing to point out when other
countries are deviating from that to
file comments to raise concerns to give
speeches so I've gone to China 10 times
with the Commissioner so in the last
five years and I went my first visit
here in 2013 I was the first US
antitrust official there and lived at
least in the last eight years or so to
go and say here is where you're off base
people often go and say a lot of
platitudes cooperation you know
globalism that's all nice but we also
need to engage and say here is where you
are deviating from what antitrust is
really supposed to be about I think one
of the other things
is to explain to them why it's not in
their interest so a lot of the a lot of
the empirical work that I've done is to
show this strong correlation between
protecting IP rights and having an
innovative economy and as for example
China or other parts of the world want
to move away from a copying economy to a
more inventive economy respecting IP
rights will be in their own interest so
that's another thing that we need to
explain to them it's very easy to go and
say you're doing X and here's why it's
not in the US interest but it's a lot
more persuasive to go to them and say
you're doing X and here's why it's not
new your interest so those are some of
the the tools there are so trade
remedies but that is done not really
through the Federal Trade Commission but
through the trade you know you STR and
think and things like that if it gets to
an extreme level okay that's an
economist I'm kind of two minds on
patents because on the one hand patents
encourage innovation that's cool on the
other hand patents create monopolies I
hate that so one interesting kind of
remedy that I've heard about is the idea
of patent buyout where if the government
recognizes there's a really valuable
patent that some firm holds and it could
be beneficial for other firms to get a
hold of that technology the government
could basically come in give that firm
the capitalized value and then put the
innovation and the technology into the
public domain for all to use so we still
have the incentive effective patents and
then we would the limit tend to reduce
the monopoly effect I just liked your
comments on that idea I think that view
has a lot more confidence in the ability
of the government to second-guess the
free market than I would feel
comfortable
and I think it also mixes up this idea
that monopolies are bad you know a
monopoly that isn't achieved through
superior innovation and through you know
giving a better product to customers you
know that that you know that's not great
but a monopoly that's achieved through
doing a better job and giving people
what they want is is really the reward
for that for that innovation so I think
that view mixes up static and dynamic
competition right so you're saying oh
it's my explanation of no oh there are
10 competitors say and everyone has to
share for that product but who's going
to go and invest to create the next best
product the next product it's going to
revolutionize the industry if they have
to share it with with everybody I think
when you look at it and that way you
realize how you're you're undermining
incentives create and so going back to
pharmaceuticals there is not a whole lot
of pharmaceutical innovation occurring
around the world it's really occurring
in the u.s. we're a company that invents
that new blockbuster drug that makes us
all better off can reap the rewards for
them we have time for one more question
yes this relates to the trans-pacific
partnership which of course became a
great political football was kicked
around and succumbed in the last
election and so forth but but part of
the TPP was designed to stabilize or
strengthen intellectual property rights
which would have been apparently greatly
to the benefit of American firms at
least that's what I've heard your you
would know more about this than
and then what I've heard so how
important or how problematic has the
failure of the TPP to move forward been
for enforcing American intellectual
property rights internationally and what
can be done about that so I'm not a an
international trade expert so I'm in
antitrust expert but I do think one of
the challenges is where you know we
really need to be alert right so you
might say you have a an agreement that
prevents piracy right so piracy that's
not lying you know just outright copying
not permitted but what are the other
regulatory or legal tools that can be
used to achieve the same goal without
calling it piracy and so that's really
where I focus my attention on this
reinterpretation of what antitrust law
is supposed to be about to achieve the
bad ends that were prohibited and things
like TPP and we have seen this problem
occurring throughout Asia India you know
some other parts of the developing world
where antitrust now is being morphed
into this tool to allow for sharing at a
government determined price not a free
market price for for the important
technology
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]